you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 2004 wreck avec rapid between
magnus carlsen and garry kasparov this
was their very first encounter carlson
still 13 years old and an international
master at the time 24 84 feet a rating
and Kasparov having a rating of 28 31 at
the time so let's dive right in here
again Carlsen on the white end playing
d4 Kasparov responding d5 and we get
right into the Cambridge Springs defense
which is denoted by the move Queen to a5
which is doing a few things first and
foremost getting out of a pin secondly
placing white in a pin and you might as
well start to already view the Queen
doing a third thing namely functioning
laterally because at any moment there
could be this captured D take C and in
many instances it could be netting black
some material I'll touch on that and a
little bit from now but before I get to
it let me point out that if this happens
to being an opening you play as white or
black there is a a neat little trap I
guess you could say that could come
about but it shows itself with the
slightly tweaked move order so let me
just touch on that very quickly and it
runs with after c4 we're not having c6
but rather a 693 Knight f6 Bishop g5 and
Knight here so we're looking at again a
similar position but the difference here
is that the moves Knight f3 and c6 are
absent and the thing to be cautious of
as white is to well really resist the
temptation to go ahead and win upon
because you're not winning upon in the
following way this is actually falling
for what's known as the elephant trap
where after white takes on this square
trying to exploit this pin black could
simply ignore it and it's a very very
temporary Queen sac
black getting the White Queen back just
a couple moves later and after the smoke
is cleared black is simply up at night
this of course is not going to happen in
the high level games but something to
certainly be aware of should you already
have this as part of your own opening
repertoire as again white or black so
getting back on with the actual game
after this Queen a5 move white takes
immediate action against this pin
breaking it with Knight to d2 and also
watching over this efore square either
one of these Knights is now able to
watch over that efore Square and this is
already a very important detail because
if white is just going to be running
with a very natural looking type of move
such as Bishop to d3 preparing to castle
watching over the e4 square black could
still just throw that Knight into that
e4 square adding more fuel to that c3
Knight pressure on the bishop and there
is an interesting sequence of moves if
you know gets to be too much on the
white end and white wants to remove one
of the attackers of that c3 square with
vision takes 9 well now we have D takes
ear yeah D takes E which is clearing
this fifth rank for that black queen so
995 is pretty much the only move to save
that Bishop and then we kind of get into
a little bit of a wacky variation here
with that after f6 could have Queen - 8
h v g6 Knight takes pawn takes Queen
takes rook Queen takes Bishop and this
is a really weirdin bounce but black is
actually the side that's going to stand
better even though it seems like their
King is a little bit shaky the Queen
alone is not going to be enough to
disrupt that black Kings position if we
were to take it a couple moves further
pretty much have this situation right
here where these bishops are going to be
ready to just strike at that white King
very
soon the bishop coming out maybe to this
diagonal the other bishop making use of
this diagonal and the queen is a
difficult piece to be chasing off of
these very weak light squares on the
white side so again just be aware of
that third detail when the Queen does
play to a5 here again off of the
diagonal functioning on this one and the
lateral movement shows itself in many
variations so Knight d2 breaking the pin
Bishop b4 persistent on this c3 point
Queen to c2 letting support black
castles Bishop e2 and E 5 so striking at
the white center right here with this e5
move and at a later point looking to
develop this Bishop however in this game
that Bishop really does just sit on that
c8 square for some time in fact it
doesn't even move until move 29 so
there's quite a bit of stuff that goes
on before this Bishop moves and well
actually even the that rook as well so
Bishop has to move before this guy could
get out of the corner so there is an
important detail right here and it's
once again focused on this lateral
movement the difference between e 2 and
D 3 is really the the whole game really
because if you play here there we go
game over can you believe it believe it
because we have the bishop pit and this
Bishop it and there is no in-between
move for white because black says no my
in-between move is even stronger taking
the taking the bishop being on the Queen
and only then recapturing and we once
again have a situation where black is
just up a minor piece so the difference
between Bishop to d3 and Bishop to e2 as
was played in the game is a very
significant one so e v striking in the
center white now fully developed that's
noted by a direct connection between
those rooks
Knight b3 hitting the Queen and when I
initially saw this okay clean goes back
to b6 when I initially saw this I
thought okay the knight pivoted they're
hitting the Queen and then would be
recapturing and I guess this is maybe
with somewhat solid approach to it not
having to cope with an isolated Queen
pond type of position which is the type
of structure we end up having to work
with on the white end here so we'll see
how that shows itself what's also
important to note is that if in this
situation Knight takes pawn was played
and the bishop takes the knight again be
aware of this knight pivot to the e4
square if Queen takes then this is this
is big trouble so white would be needing
to capture with the pawn in that
instance but we don't have the recapture
on this square right here with that b3
Knight but rather eat XD and after D
take C Bishop takes see there we have it
isolated Queen pond and so this is a
dynamic advantage here for white white
is looking to maybe press forward in the
center at some point change the pawn
structure and show you know the show
that this lead and development that
white has is going to prove useful
proved to be actually an advantage so we
have a five and then a four this is very
a very typical idea to be aware of
Knights that find themselves on b3 b6
jeath and g6 g3 are often chased away
with these rook rook pawns and often
becomes very difficult for that night to
have a good good reaction to a threat
when other rook pawns come down to
attack it so white stops that cold with
a form and I think that this is a little
bit of an uncomfortable move to have to
make I really do like this a5 move after
okay after a four because you know now
this is
now this is a whole this Bishop is able
to kind of just sit there and maybe one
day one of these nights let's say the
one on d7 could somehow make use of that
square as well so there is a little bit
of a concession but the main point is to
preserve this Knights position for the
time being so Queen back c7 functioning
on this diagonal right now that h2 point
rook to e1 getting it doing something
the bishop gets kicked around Bishop d6
and now h3 and then okay Knight to b6
now at this point I was actually when I
first reviewed I was looking at g5 and
then I'm like well where is the
compensation exactly where is this
compensation and it completely slipped
my mind that hey what do we have going
on here this is something I should have
been thinking all the while this pawn is
pinned and a pinned piece is a powerless
one this could be a deadly check in fact
it would just be a winning shot at this
very early stage as soon as g5 is played
just boom check take check Knight blocks
grab another pawn the positions
crumbling the king is dead so just be
aware of that that bishop on c4 in fact
you might as well already in your own
internal dialogue in your own thinking
when you're playing the game as soon as
this bishop makes the capture on c4
might as well just start saying okay
that pawn is pinned and maybe there's a
way to be making use of it you know
maybe you could be making use of this
square right now it's not super clear
where you could be doing that in this
case just yet but definitely at this
point right here as soon as h6 is played
you could be making use of that square
one day anyhow Bishop back Bishop d6 h3
Knight b6 hitting the bishop and this is
definitely one of those positions where
black has to come up with something
because it's really a case where black
is in a giant knot because look at these
Queen side pieces they're just
spectators what are they doing and what
is this Knight doing it
a complete domino effect really if this
night can't move this Bishop can't move
and if this bishop can't move this rook
can't do anything and the sad thing is
that if this Knight does move it I mean
it does move in the game it goes to b6
but because of the pressure this is what
I'm getting out because of the pressure
that white has against this Knight it
just kind of bottles up this whole Queen
side it's its influence is a tremendous
one so we have both both sides basically
going into a pretty big thing here well
really Kasparov at this point Knight b6
because we have a you know a couple
captures going on here there's not just
this typical capture and then recapture
stuff going on now we have after Bishop
takes on f6 Knight takes c4 and white
doesn't react to the threat on the
bishop a rather Knight to e4 a counter
attacking them centralizing the knight
hitting the bishop and also hitting this
Knight right here black responds first
inserting a Czech king h1 only move and
now this is where there is maybe a
slight improvement on the black end
because now it's white who really
dictates the game and obtains a very
strong initiative and in fact throughout
this whole game White was never worse
off White was always slightly better and
now things become even worse for black
in the game we saw Knight d6 and the
continuation was king takes bishop which
is welcoming one of these which well
it's welcoming one of these very
devastating moves just one of these
discovered checks but it's not so
disturbed devastating in this instance
right here after Knight captures on e4
we have just the counter attacking
Bishop to e5 and unfortunately black is
having to work themselves back into a
pin in order to preserve that night the
alternative is to not play 96 but rather
b5 maintaining this Knights position
and I believe light would soon be having
to react to just this pond takes bishop
move but we don't have that we b5 was
not played the night actually reacts to
that Queen threat 96 working working
again themselves Carlson working himself
into a pin right here or a discovered
attack Knight takes Bishop back Knight
d6 and here we go if one of the pieces
is in a pin what do you do you add fuel
to it Queen c5 two pieces hitting and
again White is dictating the game from
here has the initiative in other words
d5 throwing punches at white hitting at
c6 vacating d4 the knight is looking to
centralize itself all the while these
two again are still just camping out
here on the Queen side not doing a thing
so Queen to d7 and natural reaction to
being in a pin get out of it Knight d4
more pressure on c6 and Knight to f5 an
important point is this one right here
in fact if you want to stop the video
and see what would you do in this
instance right here again if you'd like
to pause the video what would be the
winning continuation for white in this
position okay the sequence of moves
which would absolutely kill black is
just to take the knight and then at the
end of it we're having this check and
then again not the first time we're
seeing this idea piling up on the pinned
piece the pinned piece is the bishop
it's dead and so too will be that black
King soon enough so in other words C
takes D don't do it Knight f5 instead D
take C I'm the queen bee take C Knight
takes pawn white is up upon the knight
is within checking distance hitting the
rook things are very uncomfortable for
black again these guys a couple clowns
right here on the Queen side
rip to e8 in the meantime rook d1
Queenie 6 and we have
rook F to e1 which is a very natural
looking move it's a very human-like to
be making this type of move it's just
tidying everything up centralizing these
rooks and now we just have all of the
white pieces functioning
however the improvement is going to be
this move right here which is well I
guess not so human-like because it's not
it's not harmonious the pieces this
bishop right now on that c7 square is
not protected when when there's this
rook F to e1 move again everything is
nice and cozy here everything is
defended the rooks guarding one another
controlling all these central squares
but this Bishop to c7 move would have
been the more accurate thing to do I was
well I'm not aware of what the time
constraints were or what the time
controls were at that at that very
moment but what is this move doing it's
just adding a what is now a third
attacker to that a5 pot and if that goes
we're going to have these prongs right
here these connected past a and B pawns
that's going to be a very strong thing
so I was not played and instead again
rook F to e1 and finally move 29 we're
having that Queen Bishop do something so
it throws itself on a very a very good
diagonal main light square diagonal and
now we have the knight coming back this
fork going on and actually even though
white is up upon there's not really
going to be a way to convert it in fact
this endgame just kind of it kind of
goes to nothing right here it gets to a
position where white really can't make
use of that extra pawn because in its in
large part to these guys being on
opposite colors opposite color bishops
will often translate into a draw and
this position right here is no exception
so we just have a little a lot of
logical moves just going on here then
of one move threats attack of the pond
defense of the pond that sort of stuff
additionally you know when this bishop
was was threatened right here with f6
what do you want to do you want to react
but still be aggressive in some way so
that's why it's coming to that c3 square
so the rooks come off the roof defends
the Kings improve their position this is
an endgame the Kings need to be doing
stuff and now the bishop is looking to
make sure this pawn doesn't get out of
control a5 Bishop back f3 and you'll
notice it's not by chance that we're
kind of having it we're having right
here on both sides these sorts of
structures you really don't want to be
too careless right here with let's say
white and we can making a move like f4
I'm sure it's still okay but it's kind
of allowing for maybe the bishop to get
on this diagonal and maybe the rook one
day being able to get on this second
rank and easily converge on that g2
square however if this type of structure
is maintained the pawns on f3 and g2 in
similarly g6 and f6 both structures are
combating or taking into account the
opposing bishops in how they can maybe
be putting pressure on the base points
g7 + g2 to be making this does turn out
to just be a draw
we have rook to h1 getting out of this
pin if there is any chance for a win on
the white end they're needing to keep
the rooks on the board and so that's why
we're having like throwing a check the
King goes back the bishop plays to c5
the rook now has the opportunity to get
to this active second rank and get
behind the past problem this is the
ideal placement for of rook defending
against a past part and you would like
to get it behind the pawn King goes back
to g3 defense rook a to Bishop d6 King
f7 rook c1 getting this pawn involved
guarding some dark squares against that
white King rook check King g6 rook c6
placing the king and a pen by that pond
and a pen maybe looking for a bishop to
d4 but no white could put pressure on
this pond right here and white just
defends by playing Bishop to f2 and a
draw was agreed at this point so
thirteen-year-old magnus carlsen drawing
the legendary garry kasparov a really
really incredible thing to have happen
there there is nothing more at this
point I was wondering if there was
something like Bishop to d4 but
something is calm as rook to a6 and
there's nothing to do this is definitely
a drawn position but as it was in this
game after Bishop to f2 both players
agreed to a draw so that's all for this
video as always I hope you got something
out of it take care bye
you